salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui on s'est arrêté sous un petit
pont qui est très sympa c'était pas
prévu mais ça va être pas mal quand
elle est là ainsi que rasta allez là
j'ai quelque chose si je l'ai pas perdu
ah oui une pile allez ça commence à des pollutions
1er lancer une pile ça fait plaisir parce que ce
pont n'a l'air de n'avoir jamais été fait
donc ça voudra bonjour vous connaissez
c'est des aimants
il y a plein de choses
oh non
moi aussi en même temps ah non
couper
je sais pas ce qu'il en est de
toi voilà je vais venir ouais
bien coincé comme il faut mais
on peut reprendre la pêche j'ai
donné une cuillère de pêche au
pêcheur qui était en haut du pont
et on va voir ce qu'on trouve d'autre
ici sous ce pont ouais une pince regarde
presque tous les coups je pense
que ça a jamais été fait ici
en fait on le sent au poids quand on a
quelque chose accroché on le senté puis
d'un coup on sent le tic et après c'est
le dessus plus lourd [Applaudissements]
il y a du poil
alors
[Musique] on a une fourchette
bonne balade merci vous aussi sur Internet maison
de la détection ça s'appelle
oh elle est pleine [Rires]
0423 elle est bonne
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais alors
ça c'est la première fois que ça nous arrive
très anciens ah ouais Nokia je sais pas
le modèle si vous savez 33 c'est lancé
tiens le portable c'est cool ça
a été filmé
j'ai quelque chose c'est sûr c'est
bizarre drôle de forme encore
petite 5 centimes d'euros ça
fait toujours plaisir [Musique]
allez devine l'année non elle a tournage
et oui une 99 c'est les premières c'est ça
alors quant à mon frère ça a lâché tu es pas
content alors moi je vais trouver quelque chose
puisque le grand frère ne fait plus le travail
rasta c'est quoi cette position là regarde le
[Musique]
mais il est couché sur le
muret là où il y a qu'une patte
j'ai mal entendu peut-être mais j'ai
cru comprendre on a le droit à une bière
peut-être que c'est un petit peu pour eux que
on va l'entendre tout de suite en fait parce que
c'est pas la chaîne d'un bateau
[Rires]
velsen velsen en tout cas bien sympa
bien ça passe cette petite réaction là
ça c'est une scène qui va devenir culte je pense
avec le sursaut de tout le monde alors là c'était
vraiment tout au fond vraiment tout au milieu du
pont donc c'est très bon signe et un certain poids
c'est une échelle un truc comme ça
on va là je me suis mis sur le
pont donc on va voir ce qu'on
peut attraper d'ici normalement il y a une
plus grosse surface là j'ai quelque chose
ok rien d'intéressant c'est assez
lourd oh oui bobine de cuivre ok sympa
toujours cool de faire un peu de cuivre
je crois que c'est bon pour c'est bon pour ce côté
du pont et je pense pas qu'on fasse
l'autre on a un petit peu pressé par
le temps on va changer d'endroit on roule
toujours très doucement sur les ponts et
voilà celui-là nous a dit quelque chose on s'est
arrêté on a fait quelques travails originales donc
ça valait le coup c'était bien sympa on va goûter
la bière on va vous faire la séance de dégustation
alors on a péché cette bière sans alcool je vous
rappelle dans les bières on va essayer d'ouvrir
avec cette pince pêcher sans alcool aussi et
pêcher et pêcher comme dirait les fumeurs il faut
bien mourir de quelque chose nous on va mourir
en buvant cette bière et en attrapant le café
en tout cas à l'odeur elle a l'air bien
de la force
super fraîche
blague mais ça reste de la saison
il y a une date non normalement
bien sympa encore une fois très joli très joli
endroit très calme on va voir ce qu'il y a parce
que c'est une route qui est quand même bien
passante j'ai jeté là j'ai senti plusieurs
choses on va voir c'est le premier lancer donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a ok ok donc on a une pince
alors celle là je peux vous dire qu'elle a vécu
et ensuite ça on reste sur
de la ferraille classique
les gants ça suffit pas toujours pour les hameçons
elle me paraissait énorme
cette pelle mais vraiment
mais c'est peut-être parce que tout
le reste non mais en termes de taille
ah oui ah oui ah ouais ouais ça
c'est une vraie pelle mais bon
elle est totalement mangée oui regarde
par rapport à ma tête quand même ouais
c'est vrai c'est de la pelle
voilà mais là elle est foutue
comme le pont d'avant
une pièce surtout elle est grosse c'est du
franc c'est du franc et du franc et du frein
hop dans la poche on se rend maintenant
au troisième spot de cette vidéo où on
a rejoint Maeva une abonnée allez vas-y
premier lancer premier lancer de la bonnet
facile facile et normalement si
tu sens un truc bon signe un bois
ça compte tu peux le sortir
tu es content de ta Troyes
pour l'instant meilleur 3D de la journée
comme ça
tu peux trouver la vie qu'il y avait avec
maintenant on a déjà fait
des soutiens-gorge comme ça
moi j'ai un truc
morceau de poteau électrique
ou 50 mais là c'est bizarre ce qu'il y a au mieux
ça glisse dessus
[Musique]
ouais j'ai filmé bien joué
on met la bonne musique là
c'est quoi morceau de scooter je crois morceau
de cadre de scooter alors bien joué Samsung
c'est pas un Wiko
bien joué sympa
tu devrais trouver des clés de voiture
c'est comme les iPhone bon tu
viens m'aider je suis bloqué là
ça suffit pas ça pour une journée non
dommage ça lâcher ah oui voilà pour la
petite pièce de 5 centimes tout propre oh non
c'est pas le poisson c'est la
ferraille tout ce qui est magnifique
des vélos
c'est notre chaîne YouTube
ouais des fois il y a des choses
sympas mais là on a fait un portable
il y a des armes des coffres-forts des
grenades un peu comme votre t-shirt des fois
et du coup ouais on va essayer
ouais ouais c'est dingue
c'est incroyable donc là j'ai trouvé une
corde on va voir ce qu'il y a au bout oh
non c'est pour les poissons ça non
je crois que c'est pour garder
les poissons dans l'eau ça
a le droit de l'essayer
américaine
super
oui oui oui ok ça va être la partie
d'un très ancien moteur quelque chose
dans le genre si vous avez une idée en
commentaire ah oui une boule de pétanque
franchement elle est en bon état ouais
dedans non vide oh il y a une pièce en plus
c'est un demi franc
ouais de l'année 1966
pas mal
rata
allez
c'est bien allez va là-bas
c'est bien
ah ça fait une pièce une pièce une
pièce oui j'ai deviné les neuves
italienne 1977
elle est trop belle magnifique
de base
pour les abonnés qui nous regardent en mangeant
tu viens de la pêcher
par contre c'est petite
[Musique]
ah punaise mais oui exactement
c'est ça
on a même le téléphone si vous
voulez vous abonner à sa page
elle est toujours dehors
pas mal de trucs une trouvaille une trouvaille
ça va mieux
bon ben voilà on a fini ce pont et là
c'est un pêcheur qui nous a dit qu'il
y avait déjà 10 pêcheurs allemands
qui étaient là il y a quelques jours
une armée de pêcheurs donc arrêtez de faire
comme nous c'est réservé aux professionnels
en vrai ça fait plaisir c'est de plus
en plus propre c'est cool mais voilà
quelques belles trouvailles quand même
le petit portable bien intéressant des
pièces moi je suis content de ma pièce italienne
productif hein c'était vachement intéressant
ouais franchement juste le fait de sentir que
tu as pêcher quelque chose à savoir
ce qu'il y a dessous etc c'est super
intéressant prochaine fois si tu es dispo
on ira à Toulouse là normalement je suis là
c'est important très important pour la pêche
pas de souci allez à la semaine prochaine